يزيد الشتاء المصاعب التي تواجه النازحين
في مخيم الشيخ مصطفى شمالا ادلب
وجود المخيمات في الاراضي الزراعيه وعدم
تعبيد طرقاتها يتركانها للاوحال في الشتاء
هذه خيمه عائله ابو محمد
الجد والجده على فقر حالهما يربيان ثلاثه
من احفادهما تسال جده الى ابقاء الخيمه
دافئه لذلك تلازم بابا المدفاه طوال الوقت
وما تستخدمه لاشعالها تخمد ناره بسرعه
ويتخاف ان يبرد حفيدها المريض
كانت كانت تحفه كانت جخه هلق ماء من هون
ومي من هون ولا عجزت انا عاجبه ما بحسن
مثل الاوله ما بحكي والله صعب علي
الطينه
ودخان المدافئ المنتشر بصحه الاطفال
ومخزون العائلات من الحطب الصغير ينفذ
بسرعه بسبب شده البرد ورغم تجديد مجلس
الامن الدولي اليه ايصال المساعدات
الامميه فانما يصل النازحين لا يسد حاجتهم
كما يقول ابو ضياء مدير المخيم
وابتدي المناظره يتوزع السله الشهري كونه
المخيم مكفول من منظمه واحده هاي السنه
بتكفي الناس لمده اسبوع او 10 ايام بكثير
فباقي الشهر الناس تتدين المحلات سمعني
بالشهر القادم متجه المنظم بتوزع السله من
جديد الناس اكثر الناس بتبيع السله لا
توفى الدين بكل الناس انكسرت على الشعر
كله
يفتقدوا النازحون في المخيمات الخدمات
الاساسيه فيما يتعلق بالصحه والتعليم
والامن الغذائي
وخيامهم ليست مزوده بعوازل تمنع البرد
ظنوا ان اقامتهم هنا مؤقته لكن مشوارهم
طال واستمرت معاناتهم
يشير ارتفاعه ارقام المحتاجين الى
المساعدات الانسانيه في مخيمات النازحين
شمال غربي سوريا الى ان اوضاع النازحين
تتجه من سيء الى اسوا في ظل ضعف استجابه
المنظمات الدوليه خاصه في فصل الشتاء شديد
البروده صهيب الخلف الجزيره ادلب